CHARLIE KURT, STEVE MOORE AND
LISA BOOTH.
I’LL KICK THINGS OFF WITH A
COUPLE POINTS.
FIRST, THERE WON’T BE A
RECOVERY UNLESS WE REOPEN
SCHOOLS NOW.
IF CHILDREN CAN GO TO SCHOOL,
PARENTS CAN GO TO WORK.
WERE TOLD SCHOOLS MUST BE
CLOSE TO KEEP KIDS SAFE BUT
THEY’RE NOT IN DANGER.
CHILDREN UNDER 18 MAKE UP ONLY
2% OF CASES.
CHILDREN UNDER 14 MAKEUP.
[INAUDIBLE]
NOW, THE MEDIA MISINFORMATION
MACHINE THAT’S FEAR MONGERING
ABOUT A NEW MYSTERY DISEASE
THAT AFFECTS CHILDREN.
DOCTOR FAUCI IS PUSHING BACK
ON IRAN PAUL’S RECOMMENDATION
FOR SCHOOLS.
CAN CHILDREN INFECT OTHERS?
WERE CONSTANTLY TOLD TO FOLLOW
THE SCIENCE AND THE DATA WELL
HERE IT IS.
ONE STUDY FOUND QUOTE, EVEN IF
CHILDREN DO GET INFECTED THEY
ARE LESS LIKELY TO TRANSMIT
THE DISEASE TO OTHERS THAN
ADULTS.
WE HAVE NOT FOUND A SINGLE
INSTANCE OF A CHILD INFECTING
PARENTS.
THEY LECTURE US ABOUT CONTACT
TRACING.
THEY DID IT WITH CORONAVIRUS.
THEY FOUND THAT EVEN THOUGH HE
CAME INTO CONTACT WITH 172
CLASSMATES AND TEACHERS WHILE
SYMPTOMATIC, HE DIDN’T
TRANSMIT THE DISEASE TO ANY OF
THEM, NOT ONE AFTER THE 172
PEOPLE.
IN SWITZERLAND THEY SAID NOW
NO YOUNG CHILDREN DON’T
TRANSMIT THE VIRUS.
AND, BECAUSE OF ALL THIS,
FRANCE, ISRAEL, GERMANY,
PORTUGAL AND MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE BEGUN LETTING
THEIR CHILDREN BACK INTO
SCHOOL.
TWO WEEKS AFTER DENMARK OPEN,
SCIENTISTS IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES SAID
THERE ARE NO SIGNS WHATSOEVER
THAT THE PARTIAL REOPENING HAS
CAUSED A BIGGER SPREAD OF
INFECTION, YET STILL THE
SCHOOLS HERE ARE CLOSED, EVEN
IN STATES WHERE BARS AND
RESTAURANTS ARE REOPENING.
WHERE IN ALL THIS IS OUR OWN
CDC BY THE WAY, WHY DO WE HAVE
TO RELY ON SCIENTISTS FROM
SWITZERLAND, DENMARK, ICELAND
YET ANOTHER REASON FOR THE
BUNGLER IN CHIEF, USELESS
DOCTOR ROBERT REDFIELD TO GO.
MEANWHILE THE MENTAL HEALTH
TOLL ON CHILDREN GOES BY THE
DAY.
ALL OF IT IS HURTING THE
POOREST AREAS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN REMOTE PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY WITH UNRELIABLE
INTERNET AND THE POOREST
FAMILIES.
ANY LEADER ANYWHERE IN AMERICA
WHO IS NOT PLANNING TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS NOW, NOT IN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS, NOT IN THE FALL,
BUT NOW IS A DATA DENIER AND A
SCIENCE DENIER.
IT ON WITH IT.
REOPEN SCHOOLS NOW BEFORE YOU
DO EVEN MORE NEEDLESS DAMAGE.
FOR ONCE WE REOPEN SCHOOLS AND
BUSINESSES WE CAN’T HAVE
STUPID REGULATIONS STIFLING
RECOVERY.
SO WHAT’S THIS UNSCIENTIFIC
NONSENSE ABOUT TEMPERATURE
CHECKS.
TOTALLY POINTLESS.
YOU’LL MISS MOST PEOPLE WITH
CORONAVIRUS AND CATCH MANY WHO
DON’T HAVE IT.
IT’S COMPLETELY ARBITRARY
SOCIAL DISTANCING RULES.
33%, 50%, WHAT’S EVEN BASED
ON, ONLY ONE OR TWO PEOPLE
ALLOWED IN AN ELEVATOR AT ONE
TIME, GOOD LUCK TRYING TO
REOPEN NEW YORK LIKE THAT OR
ANY DOWNTOWN BUSINESS QUITE
FRANKLY.
THIS OVER PRESCRIPTIVE
REGULATION IS TYPICAL OF THE
MINDSET OF OUR TECHNIC
TECHNOCRATIC ELITE.
IF YOU BOSS PEOPLE AROUND WITH
ARBITRARY RULES THEY WILL
RESIST BUT ASK PEOPLE TO
BEHAVE RESPONSIBLY WITH COMMON
SENSE AND THEY WILL.
THAT’S ALSO WHY LIABILITY
PROTECTION FOR EMPLOYERS TO DO
THE RIGHT THING IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF ANY RECOVERY
PACKAGE.
NEXT POINT, AND THIS
UNJUSTIFIED CLIMATE OF FEAR.
TOO MANY AMERICANS WRONGLY
FEAR THEY ARE AT RISK FOR THIS
VIRUS.
THAT’S A DISASTER FOR RECOVERY
BUT IT BECAUSE IT STOPS PEOPLE
FROM GETTING BACK TO REAL
LIFE.
OBVIOUSLY THE BEST THING IS A
VACCINE AND THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE
INCREDIBLE PROGRESS TO SPEED
UP BOTH BUT WE URGENTLY NEED
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
MOUNT A SCIENTIFIC DATA-DRIVEN
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN TO
EXPLAIN TO AMERICANS HOW LOW
THE RISK REALLY ARE FOR MOST
PEOPLE.
TWO MORE THINGS, THE SHUTDOWN
IS DECIMATING COUNTLESS
BUSINESSES.
EVEN WHOLE INDUSTRIES.
PEOPLE MIGHT BE GETTING READY
TO GO BACK TO A JOB THAT
DOESN’T EXIST ANYMORE.
WE BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE OF
SKILLS TRAINING ON THIS SHOW
AND GIVING OUR WORKERS THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO SUCCEED IN
THE 21st CENTURY.
HER WORK NOW WILL BE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT WITH A HUGE NEW LOAN
PROGRAM TO HELP PEOPLE
TRANSITION FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
TO START THEIR OWN BUSINESS.
THAT REALLY WOULD BE A
TRANSITION TO GREATNESS.
I’LL JUST END WITH THIS
THOUGHT.
ONE OF THE THINGS I’M MOST
PROUD OF IN MY CAREER AND
HELPING TO SET UP NATIONAL
SERVICE, NONMILITARY SERVICE,
I THINK SOMETHING LIKE THAT
COULD MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
HERE IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW.